even the most beautiful celebrities deal
with insecurities when it comes to
sharing photos on social media some
flesh will go to great lengths to get
the appearance of a flawless physique if
their editing skills aren't up to par
they can turn a decent looking image
into a Photoshop disaster if you're new
to our channel please subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up because today
we're showing you ten times - let's fail
to trick us with Photoshop Kim
Kardashian and blac Chyna Kim Kardashian
and blac Chyna teamed up to take a
photograph that left us all drooling the
ladies look awesome in their workout
gear but one social media users took a
closer look at the photo it was apparent
Kim had tried and failed to manipulate
the image in the background you can see
changes in the flooring and squiggly
lines on the wall next to Kim's waist
and tip maybe it's about time the
reality TV star picked up a copy of
Photoshop for dummies Britney Spears in
this picture Britney Spears is enjoying
the sunshine in front of a pool her
waist and stomach area are nice and
toned but you can easily tell this photo
has been altered when Britney edited the
space around her waist and then arethe
her arched back provide that in the slab
of concrete underneath her instead the
pool appears in the background and a
chunk of the walkways missing it's a
dead giveaway that this picture was
photoshopped
nice try Britt Kris Jenner Kris Jenner
posts this photo of herself and
celebrity chef Gordon Ramsay to her
social media account her Photoshop
skills would have been kept a secret if
Gordon hadn't posted the original
picture online when the two photos are
compared you can tell Kris gave her copy
of vibrant splash of color and she
erased the fine lines and wrinkles on
her face note to self if you're going to
alter photo make sure no one else in the
entire world has a copy of the unedited
version Miranda Kerr you would never
think a supermodel would need Photoshop
their Instagram pictures but time and
time again
Miranda Kerr has been caught red-handed
each of her edited photos turn out to be
a complete fail but that doesn't stop
her from sending her in her waist with
some help from
editing app she has denied altering her
photos but the proof is definitely in
the pudding
Aubrey O'Day Bob Rio de has reportedly
underwent many plastic surgery
procedures to change her parents but she
still goes to great lengths to edit her
photos the singer posted the photo on
the right to her Instagram and the photo
on the left was later revealed as the
original picture ivory altered the shape
of her waist to a Bolivian and she made
her hips more shapely let's hope she
took a Photoshop 101 course after this
fiasco Lady gaga
even though Lady Gaga's body may be
beautiful to us that hasn't stopped a
singer from resorting to Photoshop to
make herself look even more thin in this
Photoshop fail Gaga is doing some
stretching and there's some major signs
that you went a little too quick rate
with the editing tool the warp lines in
the background and the curving of the
walls and floor proved a go not only
Photoshop this image but you did so
clearly Mariah Carey on Thanksgiving
2016 Mariah Carey shared this picture on
social media in celebration as turkey
day mariah is holding a pie and a can of
whipped cream as she poses in a lace of
bodysuit and a pair of fitted jeans it's
just too bad the image was photoshopped
many of her followers called her out on
the distorted image reflecting in the
mirror and the warped cabinets behind
her this thing or must be proud of for
messy editing skills because she refused
to relieve this Photoshop veil from her
account Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian is
a repeat offender so we had to add her
to our list again in this picture with
her BFF Jonathan Kevin if you look in
between the two you can tell that Kim
edited the photos so much that she
erased part of her right arm if you're
so bad at Photoshop that you're
accidentally turning yourself into an
amputee it's design you should leave the
photo editing to the pros lindsay lohan
we're definitely going to need Lindsay
Lohan to pick up a Photoshop manual she
really thought she was going to fool us
into believing she drew a badonkadonk
overnight instead of pumping her bust
the entire background of the photo
became distorted the wall and the
cabinet behind her looked like they're
fading into a different dimension
Beyonce the bootylicious and flawless
singer wants us to believe she woke up
like this
to her Freya photoshopped attempts
Beyonce's just imperfect is the rest of
us in this picture these legs are
slimmed down to give the appearance of a
thigh gap she tried to pull a fast one
on us the stairs in between her legs are
all out of whack and warped pewter her
wonky photoshop skills were you
initially fooled by these celebs
photoshopped pictures leave a comment
below and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up
you